Zoe great opening preparation translated
into a comfortable middle game but I
have to say it wasn't that easy that
conversion in the middle game it wasn't
easy tell us a bit about the game and
your feelings after this important
victory for you oh actually the opening
was a complete surprise for me because
Rochelle usually plays the sloth rarely
plays the qgd and then she's never
played this A6 line before I remember
the E4 Knight G5 sharp sack of Peace
ideas from previous study but that was
from a long time ago so I really wasn't
sure so I started doubting myself in the
opening I feel like I spent too much
time and then later they did come up
with this brand yeah D5 once D5 comes in
and then I get rid of my eyesight Pawn I
feel like whites has to be fine rookie7
was a bad move I think she might have
missed that Bishop F4 and then the night
on B8 hanging which means that which is
actually really annoying to deal with
because it's also guarding C6 yeah and
then later I still feel like she was
fighting yeah it was so tactical I feel
like engine will say I made a bunch of
stupid moves forget about the engine in
this type of positions right I mean it's
always about that conversion isn't it by
the way big moment at this point you had
the option of potentially repeating the
position right did you ever consider
repeating or you knew that you're better
you wanted to continue fight on so the
first time I played Knight C7 um I
pretty much knew that I wasn't going to
repeat because I thought this position I
have to be better my piece starts to
watch better than blacks I don't want to
just draw yeah but also I've um then I
started thinking for a long time and I
couldn't really find anything so I was
like just nice as I haven't gained some
time and repeat once so it was never
within your imagination that you're
going to repeat twice right three times
very nice and you decide to take only
seven and go for this line
and at this point once you played this
move Knight to E6 you started seeing
this queen takes CA right how did you
assess this you knew that you're winning
at this point or you were not really
when I played Queen F3 my idea was in
ties Knight D4 so I'd have this queen C3
Fork idea with the bishop on CA as well
but then later
um after Knight E6 I can't take the
bishop immediately because there's some
Rook da blocking or something I think um
based on my calculation yes yes and um
so then I thought G3 but I still wasn't
really sure because I thought Queen G4
would be more challenging it's not
allowing any sort of Knight G5 with
Tempo I wasn't really sure how to
continue here okay maybe just continue
still take like this
Knight of faith and just the simple
Bishop to C5 were you worried about
anything in this position I know I want
material here but after age six or
something black still has a rook and a
queen so I mean they might be able to
attack something some Queen D1 yeah he's
worried about yeah yeah well she didn't
do that she played the move Queen to H3
and it much easier transition after this
one because you're forcing the exchange
of the Rooks as well yeah well Zoe uh
you're keeping up pace with one at least
uh lee Alice is not stopping either
you're not stopping either how do you
see those last three rounds play out I
mean Carissa just lost this round also
so um I feel like technically I'm on the
clear second place that's really
surprising I mean I don't I'm still
gonna take it one at a time I'm not
really trying to aim for like first
place or whatever so I'll play it the
best I can and um hopefully I'll be
happy with my results
Zoe congratulations amazing Victory
today guys any questions on the contrary
just our congratulations Zoe we loved it
that you were played for the win and we
thought you played a really great game
uh keep it up thank you absolutely
nicely done yeah